there's two types of people there's
those who are going to go give such a
great message fashion the other side so
much that the people that agree with
this person show up but they don't
convert and there's another person
that's going to say let me tell you my
way of how I see this here and this is
how I evolved into thinking this way and
the other people say I just converted me
into thinking like that so this guy
finds a community this guy goes and
converts people we need more converters
in America that's what's lack there are
too many cowards that are running away
just to talk to people that agree with
them and it's safe we need more Fighters
that's the challenge that we're having
right now so when that guy's saying what
he's saying I don't blame him for
feeling that way maybe he's got to take
a couple communication courses